[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain a comedy family film
called i'm underage but i'm not a child
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
oriyama karine is the daughter of a
billionaire businessman oriyama kazuki
she has been treated like a princess
from a young age and knows little to
nothing about the world outside her
mansion karine has everything she wants
and her only dream is to marry a prince
one day on the morning of her 16th
birthday her personal bodyguard kaburaki
and the maids wake her up and carry her
to the bathroom karine who is still half
asleep doesn't realize she is being
picked up they bathe her and get her
ready in her school uniform after being
pampered she is told that she has
received gifts from several billionaires
from around the world like mark
zuckerberg and bernard are know she is
then seated in her limo and driven to
school like usual on her way her
classmate and friend abina isuzu brings
her flowers
like karine he also belongs to a wealthy
family he has had a crush on her for a
long time but she only thinks of him as
a friend at school karine hears the
girls gush about a good-looking guy who
has just been admitted to the school she
follows them to take a look at him
herself like the other girls karine is
also mesmerized by now tsurugi's beauty
watching him play football she instantly
feels attracted to him without thinking
much about it she walks to the field and
is hit by the ball the impact almost
makes her fall when now catches her
because of the gesture the princess
falls in love with him in the evening
her parents throw an extravagant
birthday party for her they sing dance
and have a lot of fun for her gift
karine is given a wedding dress it turns
out that a prophet had told her father
that she is bound to get married the day
after her 16th birthday the husband will
turn karine into a better person and
will provide her lifelong happiness
karine refuses to marry anyone who is
not now she throws a fit breaking the
utensils and destroying the place
without letting her father explain
himself only after he shows her the
picture of her future husband does she
realize that she is being married to now
kazuki has bought her a husband of her
choice for her 16th birthday the
following day she and now are at the
altar when they are asked to exchange
rings he claims that since they are
keeping their marriage a secret it is
better if they skip that part karine is
ready to do as he says so she doesn't
object since they are too young to be
married they have decided to not tell
anyone at school after the wedding he
brings her to his house that only has
one bedroom that is the size of her
closet at her mansion she is told that
she will have to adjust now that her
husband is poor karine is skeptical
about how two people are going to fit in
the house but she trusts her husband to
make her feel comfortable she is excited
about her first night with now but is
confused when he asks her to stay on her
side of the room he reveals that he
doesn't love her and only married her
because he wanted to inherit her
father's wealth he calls her shallow for
choosing him because of his looks and
also says that he hates her karine falls
asleep hoping that everything that
happened was just a dream when she wakes
up the next day it is already 10 am she
doesn't have a habit of waking up on her
own so she is late for school the
landlady tells her that now left early
in the morning without her karine tries
to take a shower but doesn't know how to
turn on hot water getting ready for
school is difficult for her without the
help of her maids after struggling to do
basic tasks the entire morning she
leaves for school but gets lost on the
way after wandering around the city for
hours she reaches school when it is
already over isuzu asks her where she
had been all day but karine cannot tell
him because then she would have to
explain that she got married when she
reaches home at night a furious now is
waiting for her to explain the mess she
had made in the house she cries about
not knowing how to do simple tasks which
makes him feel bad for her starting the
next day he promises to help her get
used to the new lifestyle he teaches her
to turn on hot water to clean using a
vacuum cleaner and to cook instant ramen
in only a few days karine gets used to
her new life one day she cooks a meal
for him which surprisingly tastes
delicious however now soon finds out
that she used almost half of their
monthly allowance for the meal as he
starts to panic karine simply calls her
father kazuki to ask for money the pair
is called to the mansion where they
explain the situation to her father he
offers to help them but now declines it
he wants to live on a budget and not
take advantage of kazuki's kindness the
parents are impressed by his wise words
i guess they forgot that he married into
the family for their money at night the
couple stays at the mansion the next
morning when they are about to leave
karine apologizes to the cooks for
always throwing their food away after
she started to cook for herself she
realized how difficult of a task it is
her parents and bodyguard kabaraki are
shocked they erupt into cheers claiming
that this is the first time she has
apologized to anyone during school lunch
the pair sit at different tables to not
seem suspicious karine's friend isuzu
notices her looking at now but doesn't
think much of it when a group of girls
surround now offering him food she gets
jealous and asks them to go away when
she realizes what she did she makes up
an excuse and sits back down quietly a
girl named saya looks at now and walks
away angrily now calls her by her name
which makes karine even more jealous on
reaching home she confronts him about
saya but now refuses to talk when she
insists he storms out of the house they
see each other again in the morning but
do not talk karine makes it her mission
to find out about saya and nao's
relationship she hardly has to do
anything because saya approaches her
during lunch break and asks her if she
is dating now karine wants to tell her
she is married to him but she refrains
from it saya assumes that they are
dating and asks her to break up with him
immediately she claims that he is only
dating her for money and will leave her
once his school debt is paid an innocent
karine sees no wrong in dating someone
for money in fact she is happy to give
him some since her father has a lot of
it now listens to their conversation
delighted that karine didn't overreact
at home he helps her dry her hair and is
nicer in general karine notices the
change in behavior but doesn't say
anything the next day now finds out that
karine has been passing her tests with
the help of her bodyguard and her friend
isuzu hence he starts to tutor her every
day at first karine struggles to keep up
but she soon gets the hang of it she
even takes notes in class surprising her
teacher and classmates now agrees to go
on a date with her if she gets good
grades which encourages her to study
harder one day she is in the library
when isuzu asks her if she is dating
someone karine tells him she just wants
to get better grades but he has started
to suspect her she gets an a on her next
test and is overjoyed while returning
home a crowd of men in black clothes
kidnap her they take her to isuzu's
mansion it turns out that he has found
out about her marriage to now and
doesn't approve of it he threatens to
tell the school principal about it and
get them expelled if she doesn't divorce
him immediately karina's left shocked
the guy she thought was her best friend
turned out to be an obsessive lunatic
later she is in one of the rooms of his
house when now calls her he has been
looking for her all day and is worried
she tells him everything about what
happened with isuzu and asks him to come
pick her up now doesn't think twice
before coming to get his wife he is
welcomed by isuzu's bodyguards who do
not let him see karine before talking to
him isuzu knows that now married karine
for her money he tells now that he can
never provide karine with the love and
happiness she deserves having known
kareem since childhood isuzu knows
everything about her dreams and
aspirations she wanted to dance with her
significant other as a princess and
wanted to have a grand wedding with
hundreds of guests but now couldn't even
give her that
now who has started to fall in love with
her realizes that she deserves someone
like isuzu who can fulfill all of her
wishes isuzu asks him to divorce karine
if he really cares about her when now
later meets her she asks him to come
home however now wants her to stay the
night at her parents house because his
house has no electricity she retaliates
but he agrees to go on a date with her
tomorrow and calms her the next day they
meet on a bridge and go to an aquarium
where karine had always wanted to visit
now compliments her outfit making her
blush they eat several street foods talk
about different things and run around on
the beach in the end they sit down to
talk karine lists all the things that
she has noticed about now like the fact
that he hates the noise of utensils
breaking he reveals that his mother used
to break stuff when she got mad so he
has developed a hatred for such noises
they promise to support each other for
eternity and ring a bell on a shrine
right after now suggests they get a
divorce
kareen returns home shocked and
devastated the next day now drops out of
school and gets into a massive argument
with his mother he wants to do his best
to not see karine karine's parents are
worried for her but can do nothing to
change nao's mind in the meantime isuzu
visits her and asks her to go out with
him he brings her to a palace where they
dance as she had always wanted to with
her prince karine enjoys his company but
knows that she would rather live in a
tiny home with now than in a palace
when they are done dancing isuzu
proposes to her somewhere else kaburaki
meets now and gives him the divorce
papers he also hands him a princess book
that used to be karine's favorite after
reading the book now gets to know more
about what she wants in life
it also makes him realize that he cannot
give her up at any cost he runs to
isuzu's house asking him to stay out of
his and kareen's relationship he appears
to be determined about winning her back
isuzu tells him that karine refused to
marry him because she is in love with
now he wants her to be happy even if it
means helping her get back together with
him
now happily runs back to their house
knowing that karine would be there the
two finally meet each other and kiss
karine asks him if he likes her to which
now replies that he has fallen in love
with her cut to five years later karine
and now are getting married yet again
this time the church is filled with
guests and the two exchange rings in the
last scene they kiss as the crowd erupts
in cheers subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching